première réaction effectivement le
malaise agricole va être au cœur de
cette séance de question au gouvernement
Audrey je peux même vous dire que la
moitié des questions posées aujourd'hui
auront pour thème l'agriculture à noté
aussi trois questions sur le malaise des
pêcheurs dont la colère pourrait se
joindre à celle du monde agricole et
pour passer le gouvernement et surtout
le ministre de l'Agriculture Marc fen
sur le grill si je puis dire ce sont les
agriculteur du Sénat qui monte au
créneau Laurent duplom franc Ménonville
pierre Cuper Jean Jean-Claude tissau ou
encore Henry Cabanel qui lui est
viticulteur des sénateurs qui
connaissent donc très précisément les
problèmes du secteur la disparition des
exploitations Depuis 40 ans les
accumulations de normes ou encore la
concurrence qu'il juge déloyale avec les
autres pays des sénateurs qui
demanderont des réponses concrètes au
gouvernement notamment des mesures
miroir entre la France et les autres
pays et des pistes de simplification
ettam ça va commencer très vite la toute
première question sur le thème de
l'agriculture sera posée par Franck
Ménonville merci merci beaucoup
effectivement on voit le président du
Sénat Gerrard Larcher qui vient de
s'installer au plateau qui est sorti du
cabinet de départ pour présider cette
séance vous le disiez et bien il y a SEP
questions qui sont consacrées au sujet
de l'agriculture cet après-midi cela
notamment après et bien le décès hier
sur un barrage dans l'Arriège d'une
agricultrice et de sa fille qui était
faisait partie de ce mouvement ce
mouvement agricole que l'on voit
s'étendre département en France
aujourd'hui on prend tout de suite la
direction de la séance nous n'avons pas
reçu d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le procès
verbal est donc adopté sous les réserves
d'usage Monsieur le Premier Ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues notre ordre du jour
appelle les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direct sur Public Sénat
et sur notre site chacun observera des
valeurs pour nous qui sont importantes
même essentiell le respect des uns et
des autres mais aussi très concrètement
le respect du temps de parole et je
donne immédiatement la parole à notre
collègue Franck Menonville pour le
groupe de l'Union
[Applaudissements]
centriste merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'Agriculture elle porte sur
la colère des agriculteurs qui se
propagent de façon très inquiétante dans
notre pays mais avant de la poser je
voudrais avoir une pensée émue pour
Alexandra Sonac et sa fille qui ont
tragiquement perdu la vie dans
l'Ariège comme vous le savez monsieur le
ministre la colère des agriculteurs ne
tombe pas du ciel elle sanctionne une
longue évolution au fil des années les
attentes écologiques et sociétales
pesant sur le monde agricole n'ont cessé
de croître tandis que leurs charges
administrativ et financière n'ont cessé
d'exploser à cela s'ajoutent des
politiques publiques françaises et
européennes inadaptées aux réalités
quotidiennes de leur métier de moins en
moins compétitive notre agriculture a
subi un véritable déclassement résultat
nous importons aujourd'hui 2,2 fois plus
qu'en 2000 à horizon 2027 nous pourrions
même perdre notre indépendance la
monsieur le ministre pour enrayer cette
évolution il faut agir vite et fort pour
ce faire vous devez porter des mesures
de de court terme aux effets immédiats
des fiscalisation du GNR l'octroit d'une
année blanche pour des agriculteurs les
plus fragilisés des allègements de
charge fiscal et social la suppression
des surfaces non productives vous devez
aussi vous attacher à faire veiller à la
stricte application de la loi égalime
quant aux mesures de long terme il faut
un alignement des réglementations
françaises au standards européens et un
choc de de simplification monsieur le
ministre vous disposez d'un véhicule
législatif laala comptez-vous y intégrer
des mesures fortes pour restaurer la
compétitivité de notre agriculture
soutenir cette profession aujourd'hui
désespéré et en quête de sens depuis
tant
d'années pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de l'Agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire monsieur F
vous avez la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur ménlonville merci de votre
question et je voudrais d'abord en début
de ma réponse m'associer à votre émotion
à l'émotion de toute une profession et
avoir mes pensées dépensé pour cette
jeune femme pour sa très jeune fille
pour son époux pour toute sa famille qui
a été victime hier ces deux jeunes
femmes ont été victimes hier d'un
accident terrible dans la riège et je
sais que l'émotion est très grande dans
ce département est très grande dans la
communauté agricole comme dans
l'ensemble de la communauté nationale et
je voulais m'associer à cet hommage
cette jeune femme elle défendait la
fierté de son métier elle défendait la
nécessité d'un revenu elle défendait
aussi ce qui est parfois vécu pour
beaucoup d'agriculteurs comme des
incohérences et donc nous allons
travailler pour apporter des réponses
des réponses de court terme sur un
certain nombre de sujets des réponses de
moyen et long terme premier sujet c'est
les questions de rémunération nous avons
besoin que la loi égalim soit respectée
dans son entièreté le respect des
matières premières agricoles le respect
des clauses et la nécessité de
contractualiser et les détournements
qu'on peut voir ici là par un certain
nombre d'opérateurs puis la
responsabilité que doivent prendre les
distributeurs et un certain nombre
d'opérateurs deuxième élément il faut un
certain nombre de mesures qui pourissent
répondre à des crises sur les questions
fiscales à des crises sur lesquelles on
a commencé à répondre je pense à la
crise viticole ou la crise de la maladie
hémorragique épisotique et dans la
continuité de ce que nous avons fait
depuis des années sur la crise viticole
sur la période de gel sur la maladie de
la grippe aviaire nous avons répondu en
continuité sur les crises et puis il
faut qu'on arrive à se projeter dans
l'avenir premier élément qu'au niveau
européen on retrouve la cohérence entre
une transition qui est nécessaire et une
nécessaire souveraineté qu'il faut
affirmé en européen en européen dans un
contexte où l'Europe cette année en 2023
en tout cas aura importé 40 millions de
tonnes de céréal il faut s'interroger
sur est-ce qu'on sert bien des objectifs
de souverereaineté au niveau européen
comme on les pose sur d'autres registres
au niveau énergétique au niveau
médicamenteux au niveau des technologie
l'agriculture doit être dans le même
registre et puis deuxième sujet c'est
d'assurer au niveau national plus d'un
milliard de de fonds supplémentaires sur
la transition pour accompagner nos
agriculteurs ils ont besoin qu'on les
accompagne dans les transitions y
compris face au défis
climatiques merci la parole est à notre
collègue Daniel salmon pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et
territoire merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le monde agricole est endeuillé et je
m'associe pleinement à la peine des
proches de l'agricultrice et de sa fille
décédée hier l'agriculture française est
en crise le malaise est palpable depuis
des décennies il se cristallise
aujourd'hui car la coupe est pleine le
revenu agricole chute inexorablement
alors que le prix de l'alimentation
augmente jamais la question du partage
de la valeur n'a été aussi cruciale les
marges de l'agroindustrie ont atteint 48
% en 2023 la problématique numéro 1 est
bien celle de la faiblesse du revenu
agricole qui épuise les agriculteurs
votre gouvernement et le syndicat
majoritaire font de la diversion en
réduisant la contestation à celle des
normes environnementales à la question
des j
cher le syndicat majoritaire agite
l'écologie comme un épouvantail pour
mieux masquer les échecs ministre des
politiques menées depuis des décennies
organisation d'une concurrence déloyale
confiscation de la PAC par une minorité
dérégulation des marchés vous avez fait
du budget alimentaire la variable
d'ajustement pour les plus modestes le
résultat malnutrition pour les un
désespoir pour les autres ce système
craque de tous les côtés quand
allez-vous faire œuvre de justice
sociale quand allez-vous agir pour que
les paysans et paysanes soient rétribués
à la hauteur de leur
travail répondre la parole est au
ministre
de l'agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs le S les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur vous
connaissez bien comme votre collègue
mononville ces sujets il y a des sujets
de rémunération j'ai dit les question
d'égalif c'est d'ailleurs un texte qui a
été voté et largement partagé sur N B il
faut qu'on arrive à faire respecter et
c'est l'objet des réunions qu'on aura
avec le Premier ministre avec le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
pour faire respecter et puis il faut
qu'on a un appel et qu'on pourra
partager ensemble à la responsabilité de
l'ensemble des opérateurs deuxième
élément il faut vous dites on a fait de
l'écologie un épouvantail collectivement
monsieur salmont pardon parce que quand
on vient accumuler des normes et des
contraintes comment voulez-vous que ce
soit perçu par les agriculteurs et on a
besoin collectivement de on a besoin
collectivement de
réconcilier on a besoin monsieur
salmon monsieur salmon on a besoin de
réconcilier or on est bien dans une
situation où les agriculteurs le vivent
en permanence comme une punition ou
comme une mise en accusation c'est pas
vous qui accusez mais cette question est
posée comme ça et je sais Monsieur
salmon que vous êtes sans doute l'un de
ceux qui essa de le faire avec plus de
pondération et puis on a un sujet on a
un sujet d'image il faut qu'on arrête
dans les médias et à longueur de médias
de dire du mal de l'agriculture et de de
montrer une agriculture qui n'est pas la
réalité de l'agriculture française
l'agriculture française elle est
vertueuse elle est performante elle est
qualité elle est plutôt sur un modèle
familial et donc oui il y a besoin de
transition vous m'avez toujours entendu
dire qu'il y avait besoin de transition
donc je ne me défausserai pas le
gouvernement ne se défaussera pas les
transitions mais regardezl regardonsles
à l'ône de ce qu'est la souveraineté et
de la capacité des agriculteurs à le
faire sinon on bloquera tout et on aura
avancé ni sur un sujet ni sur
[Applaudissements]
l'autrealement
monsieur le ministre vous oubliez un peu
que ça fait 7 ans 7 années que vous êtes
au pouvoir qu'avez-vous fait sur les
clauses miroir dont on entend parler en
permanence qu'avez-vous fait pour une
autre répartition de la PAC avec tous
ces oubliés de la PAC qu'avez-vous fait
pour accompagner massivement la
transition agroécologique dont on a
besoin
absolument les agriculteurs sont en
première ligne ils savent parfaitement
que nous devons agir sans tarder pour
limiter le réchauffement climatique pour
nous adapter
mais il faut les accompagner et
aujourd'hui c'est cela qui manque dans
votre politique votre politique elle est
insignifiante à ce niveau là et on
comprend bien les mois de toute la
profession donc je vous dis vous avez
passé déjà 7 ans il vous reste quelques
années
agissez la parole est à notre collègue
Laurent Duplomb pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains
Monsieur le Premier Ministre
entendez-vous le cri de colère de nos
agriculteurs ce cri je vais le faire mi
qu'en partageant tous les jours les
mêmes angoisses les mêmes
incompréhensions les mêmes révoltes ce
qui nous ce qu'ils nous disent c'est
qu'ils ne comprennent plus ce que la
France et son gouvernement veut nourrir
sans produire cultiver sans culture
élever sans élevage il n'accepte plus
les messages de condamnation de tous ces
pseudo experts Caron Clément Rousseau
qui leur donnent des leçons sur les
médias et il n'accepte plus d'être
verbalisé pour écobuage alors que durant
les émeutes des milliers d'incendies
criminels sont restés impunis il
n'accepte plus ses interdictions qui
leur empêche de faire leur travail comme
les néonicotinoïdes alors que l'on
importe des milliers de tonnes
d'aliments qui en contiennent ils
n'acceptent plus les contrôles acharnés
qu'ils traitent lorsqu'ils traitent pour
protéger leur vergers ou leur culture
alors que toujours plus d'accords de
libre échange sont signés sans contrôle
à nos frontières il n'accepte plus qu'
quand les il n'accepte plus quand les
bassines avec ces 10 ans mégabacines qui
sont le fruit d'une stigmatisation d'une
minorité qui terrorise la majorité en un
mot il n'accepte plus le poids de cette
folie administrative de cette
technocratie abrutissante qui empêche
tout qui interdit tout qui tue les
paysans petit à petit alors Monsieur le
Premier Ministre je n'ai pas de question
à vous posertant l'accumulation des
problèmes que l'agriculture rencontre
résume à elle sol le mal français les
mots ne suffisent plus à calmer ce mal
il faut des actes faites rentrer et R
vos tigres qui sont de la dral de la DDT
de l'ofb de la ddspp de l'inspection du
travail ou de la police de l'eau afin
qu'ils arrêtent cette cette pression
insupportable faites terre par des
arbitrages favorables à l'agriculture
tous ces soldats vert du ministère de
l'écologie punitive faites cesser en
même en même temps de votre propre
majorité avec un campfin promoteur de la
décroissance et du Green Deal car en
même temps ne se conjugue pas en
agriculture faites confiance au bon sens
plutôt cette cette gauche bobo qui n de
C de donner des le sang et de produire
des interdits faites écrire dans la
prochaine loi d'orientation des mesures
qui détendent la situation normative
arrêter la surtransposition et de Ren
les moyens de production libérer les
paysans de toutes ces contraintes et
laisserles travailler il demande pas de
travailler moins mais au contraire de
pouvoir de travailler
plus
la parole est au ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur DUP plomb ce n pas
la première fois que nous discutons de
sujet agricole t vous êtes engagé je
sais dans votre groupe il y en a
d'autres sur ces sujets dans cet
hémicycle vous le dites avec vos mots ce
ne sont pas les miens mais au fond le
rabol que vous exprimez
il existe et c'est ce qu'il faut
entendre et c'est ça ce qu'il faut
entendre du ralbol qui s'exprime qui est
une sédimentation d'ailleurs vous
l'aviez très bien dit dans votre rapport
avec d'autres sénateurs une
sédimentation de dizaines d'années de
réglementation superposée chacun a pris
sa part et je prends la mienne parce que
je n'ai pas de difficulté à le faire la
deuxième chose sur laquelle je ne suis
pas d'accord permettez-moi de vous le
dire monsieur duplom ne jetez pas la
vindicte populaire ou agricole les
administrations de l'État au niveau
national je vous le dis comme au niveau
territorial faisons attention prenons
nos responsabilités peut-être
disons-nous que le législateur que dans
nos réglementations nous devons donner
aussi des outils parfois j'entends des
contrôleurs qui disent je comprends même
pas la réglementation et donc il faut
aussi entendre ça et donc on a besoin de
travailler sur plusieurs sujets je
voudrais saluer le travail qui a été
fait au Sénat dans une première loi sur
la compétitivité vous dire Monsieur le
Sénateur durplomb qu'on a parfois on dit
qu'on écoute pas assez le Sénat le
Président il est souvent vigilant qu'on
a repris un certain nombre de
dispositions je pense aux dispositions
sur la compétitivité ce qu'on a fait dès
à présent sur le plan de fruits et
légumes je pense aux dispositions
c'était dans un autre texte sur les
groupements fonciers agricoles je pense
aux dispositions qu'on prend sur les les
garanties sur le foncier ou les
garanties d'emprunt tout ça rejoint la
dynamique que vous avez évoqué et que
vous avez porté ici au Sénat et puis il
faut qu'on aille plus loin ça permettra
je l'avais imparfaitement fait de
répondre à Monsieur mononville il faut
que dans la loi d'orientation on puisse
rajouter des choses sur la souveraineté
alimentaire et sur la question des
normes et puis sur le budget comme le
rapporteur M invite rappelez que cette
année vous l'avez d'ailleurs voté au
Sénat nous avons 1,2 milliard d'euros
supplémentaires de crédit pour
l'agriculture au service de la
transition de la souveraineté en terme
de protéin de la modernisation des
appareils de production c'est tout ça
qui permettra de répondre et d'abord sur
les objets de court et moyen terme et
sur le long terme les éléments que vous
venez de
poser
merci la parole est à notre collègue sa
Omar pour le rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendants
vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au Premier ministre nous avons
dans cet hémicycle avec mon collègue
sénateur tan Mohamed eu l'occasion
d'alerter le gouvernement sur un climat
social fortement dégradé dans notre île
de Maillotte mais aujourd'hui
solannellement nous voulons tirer la
sonnette d'alarme sur ce qui se passe
dans notre île à Mayotte nous subissons
depuis plusieurs années des vagues
d'immigration venant des pays voisins
les Comor et Madagascar dans un
territoire de 374 km² avec une
augmentation de près de 5 % de la
population avec une densité bien sûr de
2600 habitants au kilomè Carr un nouveau
flux de migrants venant de l'Afrique des
grands lacs et la Somalie est venu
s'ajouter ces dernières années un camp
c'est'est installé dans le stade de la
capitale mamouzu où se journent plus de
700 personnes danst des familles avec
des enfants ce camp où vivent des
Africains dans des conditions indignes
cristallise ce désarroi de la population
maoraaise qui subit crise sur crise
crise de la ressource en N crise de
l'insécurité crise des intempéries C
derniers jours sur les réseaux sociaux
certains évoquent des risques de guerre
civil et d'affrontement entre les
populations et les et les migrants nous
ne faisons pas partie des gens qui
soufflent sur les braises mais il est de
notre
responsabilité de vous alerter sur la
situation grammatique qui peut
dégénérer depuis lundi
les services publics sont fermés des
barrages sur les routes bloquent l'accès
au travail des maorés et perturbent les
établissements scolaires Mayot est au
bord du du du Cho si des initiatives
fortes ne sont pas prises très
rapidement Monsieur le Premier Ministre
ma question est la suivante face à la
situation explosive au corp d'un
territoire de la République quelle
action concrète le Gouvernement
entend-il mener pour évacuer le camp qui
s'est formé au cœur de mamouzu et enrayé
ces flux migratoires je vous remercie
pour répondre la parole est à Monsieur
le Premier
Ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Mayotte
est une terre de défi c'est une jeunesse
qui a envie de prendre son destin en
main c'est une biodiversité
exceptionnelle ce sont aussi des
difficultés immenses pour la sécurité
pour l'accès à l'eau pour nos services
publics pour l'école et vous l'avez dit
à travers votre question pour
l'imigration alors je vous le dis de
manière extrêmement claire extrêmement
déterminée avec mon gouvernement nous
sommes déterminé à continuer à agir pour
Mayotte déterminé à œuvrer avec vous
avec l'ensemble des élus avec les
Maorais pour l'avenir de Mayotte
monsieur le sénateur Mayotte connaît une
immigration forte source de tension très
grave et nous avons eu régulièrement
l'occasion d'en parler dans cette
hémicycle notre premier objectif je le
dis ça reste de prévenir les arrivées
irrégulières à à Mayotte en luttant
contre les filières d'immigration
illégal vous le savez une antenne de
l'office de lutte contre le trafic
illicite de migrants a été créé à
Mayotte au début de l'année dernière
afin de renforcer la lutte contre les
filières de passeur et en priorité les
filières africaines les résultats
commence à être là en 2023 six filières
ont été démantelées avec de lourdes
condamnations qui ont été prononcé
jusqu'à 7 ans d'emprisonnement le
deuxième objectif c'est de traiter
beaucoup plus rapidement les demandes
d'asile des migrants qui arrivent à
Mayotte parce qu'évidemment le temps
d'avoir la réponse on le sait il y a des
installations qui se font nous avons
renforcé les moyens de l'auvepra qui
disposeent désormais d'une antenne à
Mayotte nous avons également accru les
capacités d'hébergement des demandeurs
d'asile enfin le troème objectif c'est
évidemment d'expulser plus rapidement
ceux qui n'obtiennent pas le statut de
réfugié qui n'ont plus rien à faire sur
notre sol les déboutés de l'asile font
systématiquement l'objet de décision
d'éloignement ensuite il faut pouvoir
les exécuter dans les meilleurs délais
nous savons que l'enjeu il est là nous
sommes pleinement mobilisés sur ce sujet
nous obtenons là aussi de premiers
résultats encourageants mais il faut
aller plus loin et nous avons vous le
savez aussi des échanges internationaux
sur le sujet pour être plus efficace en
la matière je le dis l'ensemble de ces
mesures seront renforcées dans le cadre
du plan interministériel de lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière chikandra qui
est actuellement en cours de refonte
monsieur le sénateur vous avez évoqué
dans votre question euh un point
spécifique une situation spécifique qui
est la situation du stade de Cavani à
mamouzou où s'est installé un campement
informel de migrant et vous avez décrit
la situation je vous le dis de manière
très claire comme j'ai eu l'occasion de
le faire sur les autres points l'État
est déterminé à évacuer ce camp en lien
étroit avec les élus concernés et je
vous le dis les premières démolition
démarreront dès demain elles se
poursuivront dans les prochains jours
jusqu'à la disparition complète de ce
campement nous apporterons une réponse
adaptée à chacune des personnes
présentes sur le campement j'ai bien
conscience des mouvements qui sont nés
en réaction à l'installation de ce
campement les manifestations les
blocages de route de service public je
le dis de manière très claire le
démantèlement du camp doit permettre le
retour à un fonctionnement normal de
l'ensemble des activités c'est une
attente forte des maoraais et nous le
leur devons mais je veux aussi le dire
les violences à l'encontre des migrants
ne sont pas acceptables 11 auteurs de
ces violence ont été interpellé et
seront jugé monsieur le sénateur Mayotte
c'est la République avec mon
gouvernement avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outresm je suis
déterminé à agir pour les Maorais à agir
pour Mayot et j'aurai l'occasion de me
rendre prochainement sur place je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Pierre de viel pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et
terroire monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre ma question porte sur les
crises concomitantes de l'Agriculture et
de la Pêche tout d'abord mes pensées
vont bien sûr vers la famille Sonac si
durement
éprouvé comme prévu le blocage de de la
64 sur mon département initié par des
éleveurs victimes de la crise bovvine
MHE est en train de se généraliser à
l'ensemble du pays ns nos éleveurs ne
peuvent plus vivre de leur métier devant
tant de désespéran des mesures concrètes
et immédiates sont aujourd'hui
indispensables le gel du prix du GNR en
niveau acceptable pendant 3 ans
permettrait aux exploitants les plus
durement touchés de se refaire une
trésorerie envisagez-vous cette option
aujourd'hui le bashing agricole et
l'inflacation normative ne sont plus
supportables l'agriculture doit devenir
grande cause nationale pour
2024 que dire maintenant de la décision
ahurissante du Conseil d'État revenant
sur l'arrêté dérogatoire du gouvernement
et qui se résume à une interdiction de
la pêche pendant 30 jours dans le golf
de Gascogne les pêcheurs ont subi cet
hiver de nombreuses tempêtes les
obligeant à rester à quai cette nouvelle
punition les met dans une situation tout
à fait
insupportable alors que la gestion des
quôtas de pêche et de la ressource
aliotique ont été délégué à Bruxelles le
Conseil d'État est-il vraiment compétent
pour prendre ce genre de décision la
réalité des faits c'est qu'il n'y a
jamais eu autant de dauphins dans le
golfe de Gascogne dont personne ne
souhaite la mort évidemment doit-on
sacrifier toute une filière pour
satisfaire des association comme ceper
France Nature Environnement ou la LPO où
vont s'approvisionner les marilleeurs
l'écologie punitive a fait suffisamment
de dégâts dans notre pays tournons vite
la page monsieur le ministre nos
territoires nos ports sont en détresse
absolue ne pensez-vous pas qu'il faut en
urgence penser au cevet de ces filières
sous peine d'abandonner toute ambition
en matière de souver
alimentaire pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de la transition
écologique monsieur Christof
Béchu monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Pierre
medviel vous évoquez la situation des
agriculteurs et la situation des
pêcheurs et c'est la deuxème partie de
votre réponse qui va justifier que je
vous réponde pleinement comptenu à la
fois des responsabilités que j'ai été
amené à prendre ces derniers jours et du
fait que je suis leur interlocuteur
j'insisterai pas sur l'agriculture Marc
fenau l'a fait vous citez une attente
une mesure nous attendons dans
l'après-midi les revendications précises
des agriculteurs vous savez que il y a
ce sujet sur le génère il y en a
manifestement d'autres et l'examen que
nous devrons faire il sera minutieux il
sera avec attention et il sera pas
seulement sur les mesures il sera aussi
sur le fait d'aller éviter par les mots
une absence de considération ou une
forme d'hypocrisie écologique qui
consisterait à continuer à appliquer
dans notre pays des normes pour ceux qui
se produisent ici et qui ne s'appliquent
pas à ceux qui veulent faire venir leurs
produits dans notre pays c'est la même
logique et la même réflexion que nous
devons également être capable de
conduire sur la pêche où le point de
départ est très différent le point de
départ vous l'avez dit c'est une
décision de justice du Conseil d'État au
mois de décembre à partir d'une réalité
qui n'est pas contestable le nombre de
dauphins échoués sur les plages une
espèce menacée et avec 1482 dauphins
échoués sur la seule période
hivernale d'après les spécialistes c'est
la survie de l'espèce des dauphins
communs et des marsoins communs qui est
en jeu à partir de ça une position de
compromis consistant à imaginer un
dispositif de conciliation a été mis en
place avec des dérogations le Conseil
d'État a annulé ses dérogation et il a
fait avec un délai trop bref pour que
nous puissions faire autre chose que
d'appliquer strictement cette mesure
pour avoir vu le patron des pêcheurs il
y a quelques jours pour être en dialogue
constant avec eux c'est une batterie de
mesure que nous envisageons d'abord dans
l'urgence pour faire en sorte d'assurer
des indemnisations qui ne mettent
personne sur le carreau ensuite d'quité
pour éviter que des navires non français
ne viennent pêcher dans nos eau enfin de
contrôle j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir
à l'occasion de la prochaine QAG de
cette
séance quelques secondes
monsieurur ministre R son pas la
situation sans venimer le temps des
réponses concrètes est arrivé je
pense la parole est à notre collègue
Henri abanel pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres Alexandra et
Camille sont décédés hier le monde de
paysan dont je suis les pleurent et la
France est en deuil au nom de mon groupe
j'apporte toute notre compassion à leur
famille elles sont mort en défendant le
métier et notre agriculture l'une des
plus sûres au monde dans ce contexte de
tristesse et de colère la desessence
s'impose à nous stop à la politique
politicienne ce malêtre on le connaît
depuis longtemps le rapport que j'ai
Cigné avec notre ancien collègue
François ferra en 2021 pointer les
causes multifactorielles nous ne
découvrons pas le problème du revenu une
majorité d'entre eux sont à 4,80 € de
l'heure SDC qu le SM qui est à 11,65 €
nous ne découvrons pas le problème de la
surtransposition des normes de la
lourdeur administrative du dénigrement
de nos paysan par une minorité je le
répète une minorité car 85 % des
Français les aiment et considèrent
qu'ils jouent un rôle majeur dans leur
alimentation soyons dignes ne posons pas
une agriculture contre une autre cette
diversité c'est notre richesse c'est
notre force notre agriculture doit
s'adapter aux clauses environnementales
mais sans jamais déquilibrer
déséquilibrer pardon l'économie ces
mutations prennent du temps et il ne
faut pas qu'elles crée une concurrence
déloyale les politiques publiques
doivent être pensé avec et par et pour
les agriculteurs monsieur le ministre
vous avez annoncé plus de contrôle pour
l'application de la loi égalim c'est un
minimum de faire appliquer les lois
comment et avec quels moyens pour la
dgcsrf entre autres vous êtes d'accord
avec l'objectif de simplification nous
aussi comment entraîner notre
administration dans cette voie à l'heure
où le Conseil a été remplacé par la
défiance et le contrôle demain je serai
auditionné au Parlement européen à
Bruxelles sur le mal-être des
agriculteurs je réaffirmerai
l'obligation des clauses miroir monsieur
le ministre comment convaincre vos
homologues sur cet objectif que nous
défendons
tous pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'agriculture et la
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur feno
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Cabanel vous êtes
agriculteur vous l'avez dit nous avons
souvent évoqué ces questions et je
m'associe évidemment à l'hommage que
vous avez rendu aux deux victimes
tragiques de de l'Ariège répondre sur
plusieurs sujets c'est vrai que c'est
pas des sujets qui sont tout à fait
nouveaux mais il faut qu'on essaie
d'accélérer sur un certain nombre de
procédure alors je commence sur les
sujets de simplification on a plusieurs
sujets à traiter le premier c'est celui
d'accélérer les procédures vous ne
pouvez pas avoir sur l'eau sur les
bâtiments d'élevage ou sur un certain
nombre d'investissements d'initiatives
que prennent les agricul
3 5 7 parfois 10 ans de procédure où au
fond les procédures sont utilisées non
pas pour s'assurer du bon droit ou
simplement de de de prévenir d'un
certain nombre de risques elles sont
elles sont faites et certains l'assument
comme tel pour empêcher que les projets
puissent naître et on a besoin de
regarder cette question de la durée il
me semble que c'est un élément important
deuxième élément on a besoin d'assurer
de la cohérence on peut pas à la fois
demander à un éleveur d'agrandir son
élevage parce que il y aurait des
questions de bien-être et en même temps
lui donner une procédure qui serait trop
longue et trop lourde et qui lui empêche
d'agrandir son élevage on peut pas à la
fois dire à un agriculteur il faut que
vous on maintienne le pastoralisme et
nous avons travaillé sur le sujet vous
savez qu'on a eu un débat la semaine
dernière et ne pas trouver des vois et
moyens pour trouver la la réponse à la
question de la prédation du loup et donc
c'est sur tous ces sujets qu'il faut
chercher ce que je veux montrer là c'est
les incohérences c'est comment il y a
des injonctions qui paraissent
extrêmement contradictoires aux
agriculteurs dans la diversité de leur
métier et puis il faut qu'on réponde aux
crises vous êtes dans une région n avons
commencé à répondre aux crises ça me
permettra de ondre sur la maladie
hémorragique on a commencé à mettre des
moyens sur sur la table le Premier
ministre et nous proposerons un certain
nombre de moyens complémentaires et
d'éléments complémentaires pour les
rassurer sur la viticulture et puis
dernier élément on a besoin aussi de
travailler sur les transitions il y a
des territoires en particulier les
vôtres qui sont en grande difficulté du
fait du dérèglement climatique ou du
modèle agricole qui est qui est l'heure
on a mis 200 millions d'euros sur la
table dans le dans le cadre du budget
2024 pour accompagner ces transitions
les investissements les modèles
d'agriculture c'est tout ça qu'il faut
qu'on fasse puis enfin au niveau
européen il faut qu'on travaille à la
fois sur les clauses miroires mais
d'abord je dis à l'Europe et au niveau
européen qu'il faut qu'on travaille avec
les collègues pour faire en sorte que
nous ne créions pas des normes qui
viennent entraver la capacité de
production européenne parce que sinon
nous n'y arriverons
pas la parole est maintenant notre
collègue Jean-Claude tissau pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
depuis plusieurs semaines un mouvement
agricole a émergé en en Europe et depuis
quelques jours en France où il a
malheureusement été terriblement
endeuillé il n'existe pas un malaise
dans le monde agricole mais des malaises
tant les différences entre les régions
et les filières peuvent être importantes
il y a bien sûr des éléments
conjoncturels comme les alléas
climatique sanitaire ou la situation en
Ukraine mais il y a aussi Monsieur le
Ministre l'incapacité d'un d'un exécutif
qui après plus de 6 ans au pouvoir
semble davantage s'être fait le
spécialiste des réponses d'urgence
plutôt que le porteur d'un véritable
projet et nous le constatons encore ord
avec l'è report du projet de loi
d'orientation agricole dont le contenu
actuel est en de ça des attentes des
agriculteurs mais aujourd'hui mes chers
collègues face à cette mobilisation ne
nous trompant pas de diagnosti la crise
est avant tout économique à l'heure où
les géants de l'agroalimentaire se
mènent une guerre des prix toujours plus
forte dont les agriculteurs sont
toujours les grands perdants et ce n'est
pas en cédant au lobby agroindustriel
sur l'abaissement des normes ni en
revenant sur les avanées environnemental
du pacte vert que nous répondrons à la
situation au contraire il est plus que
temps d'accompagner le monde agricole
dans cette indispensable transition pour
cela rémunérons l'ensemble des services
environnementaux rendus par les
agriculteurs retravaillons les aides de
la pack agissons pour une loi foncière
qui permette l'installation et la
transmission et encourageons
l'agroécologie initiée depuis 2014 l'un
des derniers versant et bien sûr de
reprendre la main sur la régularation
des prix les lois égalim ont été des
échecs seul un travail au niveau
européen le permettra au côté évidemment
de l'encadrement des traités de libre
échange ma question est très simple et
sincère monsieur le ministre comment v
engager cette indispensable évolution de
notre modèle agricole pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
Tiss je ne vois pas forcément maiss à
toutes les questions qui me sont posées
y compris par vous et donc j'ai essayé
de répondre sur la diversité vous dites
a une diversité des problèmes n'éludez
pas la question de la simplification ou
de la question des normes parce que ça
fait partie des problèmes qui sont poser
sur la table si on ne voit qu'un pan du
sujet on fera une erreur me semble-t-il
deuxièmement vous nous dites qu'est-ce
qu'a fait le gouvernement pardon je ne
crois pas et je ne vois pas un
agriculteur sur le terrain dire qu'il
faut revenir sur les lois Galim il nous
demande d'aller plus loin et de vérifier
qu'elle s'applique et les lois égalim
c'est ce gouvernement et pas un autre
qui l' fait monsieur tisso c'est ça la
vérité des choses de vous nous dites il
faut les accompagner dans les
transitions mais qui a mis les moyens
sur les transitions y compris en terme
de produits phytosanitaires si ce n'est
nous pardon vous avez soutenu un
gouvernement qui a interdit des produits
je pense au N nicotinoï il y avait pas
un souous pour trouver les alternatives
résultat on s'est trouvé en situation
d'impasse et donc nous nous avons mis
les moyens 250 millions d'euros avec ma
collègue qui travaille sur ces sujets de
la recherche 250 millions pour trouver
des alternatives parce que le le
déclamatif et le déclaratif sur les
transitions si on y met pas les moyens
on n arrivera pas nous le faisons sur
les fonds de souveraineté aussi et puis
troisième élément il faut qu'on
travaille au niveau européen mais
essayons de ne pas opposer les on a
besoin de tous les modèles nous sommes
une puissance exportatrice et nous avons
aussi besoin de modèles qui soi plutôt
des modèles qui viennent satisfaire nos
besoins domestiques comme on dit et donc
on a besoin de travailler sur tous ce
sujet le sujet européen le sujet de la
transition le sujet des Galim faut qu'on
aille plus loin monsieur Tiss je suis
sûr qu'on peut le partager mais ne
disons pas qu'on a rien fait en tout cas
ce gouvernement singulièrement sur ces
sujets là il a beaucoup avancé tant sur
la rémunération que sur les transitions
je vous propose qu'on essaie d'avancer
d'avancer plus loin et plus vite
monsieur
tis merci monsieur le Président écoutez
monsieur ministre vous prendre au mot
allons plus loin et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui à travers la parole de
mon président de groupe on nous avons
demandé auprès du président du Sénat
nous proposons la création d'une
commission d'enquête justement sur la
construction d'une renevenue
[Applaudissements]
agricole la parole est au président
pierreouias pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste
calaki merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
l'enseignement privé sous contrat prçit
près de 13 milliards de subversion
publique soit 75 % de leur budget total
la Cour des comptes a dénoncé les
défaillances de votre ministère dans le
contrôle de l'utilisation de cet argent
public elle alerte aussi de
l'accroissement des disparités social
entre les établissements privés et
publics les dérives d'un établissement
privé parisien que je nommerai pas pour
vous permettre de me répondre ont révél
que certains de ces établissements ne
respectent pas leurs obligations légales
et leurs contrat d'association certains
de ces établissements ne respectent pas
la liberté de conscien des élèves et des
professeurs certains acceptent en leur
sein des enseignements contraires à la
licité et aux valeurs de la République
certains laissent libre cours à des
propos contre la contraception
l'avortement et l'homosexualité et
sépare les filles et les garçons
certains refusent d'organiser la
vaccination contre le papilloma virus ou
la journée dommage à Samuel paatti et
Dominique Bernard nos martyres de la
laïcité certains ne respectent pas les
principes de parcours sup enfin certains
choisissent de ne scolariser que les
enfants des familles les plus favorisé
et n'acceptent pas les élèves en
situation de
handicap alors que le président fait du
réarmement civique de la nation la
priorité du gouvernement des
établissements subventionnés par l'État
organisent un séparatisme social et
scolaire madame la ministre il faut
mettre fin à toutes ces dérives on ne
peut accepter que deux jeunesses vivent
dans des mondes qui s'ignorent l'école
doit être le cœur du projet républicain
merci monsieur le
Président pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de l'Éducation Nationale
de la Jeunesse et du Sport monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur ououias
depuis quelques jours j'entends parler
de ce séparatisme scolaire au profit de
l'école privée je le redis n'opposons
pas l'école publique et l'école privée
qui concourent ensemble au service
public de l'enseignement en parlant pour
le privé de séparatisme scolaire vous
stigmatisez les choix de millions de
parents je suis très clairire la
République ne tolère aucun séparatisme
encore moins s'agissant de l'école
encore moins s'agissant de ses enfants
les règles qui s'appliquent aux
établissements privés sont celles de la
République et je seraiis intransigente
sur le respect de la laïcité comme sur
le respect de la liberté de l'enseigne
nous contrôlons sur le plan pédagogique
les enseignements de ces établissements
et nous travaillons aussi pour que
toutes les écoles soient engager au
service de l'égalité des chances ce qui
oui implique de progresser dans la
mixité sociale et scolaire plusieurs
expérimentations ont été engagées en ce
sens à titre d'exemple toute nouvelle
ouverture de dispositifs dit
d'excellence comme les sections
international sont désormais soumises à
ce critère de mixité sociale pour les
dispos de soutien comme devoir fait nous
posons cette obligation et nous
privilégions l'école publique dont nous
à qui nous dotons que nous dotons des
bons moyens un protocole également a été
signé avec le secrétariat général de
l'Enseignement Catholique avec des axes
très concret en faveur de la mixité et
l'ensemble de ces réseaux l'ensemble de
ces établissements seront associés à
cette démarche ne faisons pas de procès
d'intention jugez-moi sur mon action de
minist jugez-moi sur mon ambition pour
l'école publique jugeznous sur nos
résultats au service de l'égalité des
chances et de la réussite de toutes les
écoles et de tous les enfants de ce pays
je vous
remercie monsieur monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président je
ne fais pas de Procé d'intention madame
la ministre mais de nombreux
établissements privés sont aujourd'hui
hors la loi vous devez impérativement
exercer pleinement votre mission de
contrôle pour l'intérêt de toute la
République merci monsieur le
Président la parole est rapporteur
général Jean-François Husson pour le
groupe les
républicains monsieur monsieur le
ministre en présentant vos vœux aux
acteurs économiques vous avez recyclé
cette idée votre intention du
désendettement accéléré de la France en
réponse je pense à à la dérive continue
de nos finances publiques et de la
croissance irréédiable de notre dette
publique pouvez-vous nous dire monsieur
le ministre selon quelle méthode et nous
en préciser tant le calendrier que le
contenu pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'économie des finances
et de la souveraineté
industrielle merci monsieur le
Président allez-y monsieur il sont
tellement heure j'ai je me sens toujours
heureux quand je suis au Sénat monsieur
le
Président Monsieur hon j'ai envie de
vous retourner la question parce
qu'au-delà des méthodes les plans de
désendettement de réduction des déficits
il faut prendre des décisions et je dois
vous dire que je suis un peu perdu
devant l'attitude des républicains nous
venons d'annoncer des milliards d'euros
d'économie en ayant le courage de
rétablir une partie de la taxe
intérieure la consommation finale
d'électricité en sortant progressivement
du bouclier tarifaire sur l'électricité
comme nous l'avions dit et nous avons
tenu parole et nous prenons les
décisions nécessaires pour établir les
finances publiques alors j'aimerais
pouvoir compter sur l'engagement ferme
et uni des républicains mais accordez
vos violons avec vos amis députés
j'écoute Olivier marlex président du
groupe les républicains à l'Assemblée
nationale qui
dépose dépose un amendement en décembre
sur le projet de loi de finance 2024
pour établir l'intégralité de la taxe
intérieure sur la consommation finale de
l'électricité à 32 € le mgaw
c'est-à-dire le niveau d'avant-crise
nous lui disons que c'est trop nous
faisons ça plus progressivement mais je
saluais l'effort d'économie sauf que un
mois plus tard le même Olivier marlex
toujours président du Groupe R des
républicains l'Assemblée nationale
déclare déclare qu'il faut sur So
au rétablissement de la TI CFE où est la
cohérence des républicains Mesdames et
Messieurs les républicain où
habitez-vous au Sénat ou à l'Assemblée
nationale et je vois que votre candidat
François xéier bami en boîte le pas au
président du groupe les républicains à
l'Assemblée nationale et nous demande de
surçoir à cette décision courageuse qui
représente 9 milliards d'euros
d'économie alors quand on est perdu il
n'y a qu'une solution
c'est sans remettre la sagesse du
président du Sénat Gérard Larcher qui
déclarait le mardi 23 janvier sur France
Info l'abaissement la ticfe de 32 € 1 €
coûte 9 milliards d'euros il est
indispensable de la remettre en place
merci monsieur le Président nous avons
suivi votre
exemple monsieur monsieur
HSE voilà monsieur le ministre vous
multipliez à l'instant les déclarations
contre contradictoire et non suivi des
faits au-delà de la magie du verbe
l'ardoise elle n'est pas magique elle
est même au goût des Français
particulièrement salé depuis 2017 et la
responsabilité ininterrompue que vous
exercez à Bery la France est devenue le
bonedane de l'endettement en Europe
Eurostat le précise en 2016 six pays
étaient derrière la France depuis Chypre
la Belgique l'Espagne et le Portugal
nous ont relégué en queue de Ploton seul
la Grèce et l'Italie sont encore plus
endettés que la France vous dites
vouloir accélérer le désendettement
jamais commencé alors que vous êtes
monsieur le ministre euh dans
l'accélération du déclassement de la
France comment en effet parler de 33000
€ par français à près de 50000 en 2023
comment tenir avec une telle assurance
ce propos quand vous et votre majorité
aurait fait de la dette le premier poste
de dépenses de l'État devant l'éducation
nationale sous peu vraiment vous vous
vous abusez vous moquez des Français
comme du Parlement pendant des mois vous
avez été l'apôtre des économies du
dialogue avec le Parlement lui demandant
de proposer des économies et bien au
Sénat nous avons fait mieux nous les
avons voté 7 milliards d'économie et
vous inflexible vous n'en avez accepté
aucune zéro rien même pas l'euro
symbolique
empêcher à l'Assemblée nationale faute
de majorité vous déniez au Sénat la
possibilité de proposer des économies et
bien je vous le dis monsieur le ministre
ce double langage sur l'endettement de
la France et sur le Parlement ça
suffit la parole est à notre collègue
Annie leou pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain madame la
ministre dès sa prise de fonction le
Premier ministre a fait une annonce
spectaculaire 32 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour le système de santé
cette annonce a suscité de grandes
attentes et mérite des éclaircissements
qu'en est-il exactement s'agit-il
vraiment de 32 milliards supplémentaires
ou s'agit-il des 31,5 milliards déjà
engagés par la loi de programmation des
finances publiques je crains que ce ne
soit du recyclage de crédit déjà alloué
un flop donc un flop qui ne fait
qu'accentuer la déception et le désarroi
des personnels soignants auquels je
tiens à rendre hommage la santé mérite
mieux que des coups de com les Français
sur tous les territoires sont préoccupé
par l'accès au soins la médecine de
ville et les hôpitaux font face à une
pénurie alarmante de médecins et de
personnel soignant pas une semaine sans
une manifestation de milliers de
soignants d'usagers d'élus à guingan
Lanon Pontivi Carret partout en
france'exprime la détresse face au
risque avéré de naître sur les routes de
ne plus être prise en charge pour un AVC
la perte de chance et la prise en charge
tardive sont dénoncé par tous les
médecins quelle est votre stratégie pour
garantir l'accès au soins à tous partout
vous allez probablement me répondre par
les mesures prises par vos prédécesseurs
en évoquant le Ségure de la santé des
mesures d'urgence nécessaire mais
insuffisante face à l'effondrement de
notre service public le Premier ministre
a appelé à transformer le financement de
l'hôpital de manière plus intelligente
nous sommes impatients de connaître vos
propositions concrètes qualifié
d'intelligente par votre par notre
ministre de Premier ministre
pardon pour vous répondre la parole est
à la ministre du Travail de la santé les
solidarité Madame Catherine va merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs sur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et madame la sénatrice Annique
loarou madame la sénatrice vous venez
d'évoquer les dépenses de santé vous
venez d'évoquer des milliards je
rappelle que ces milliards et c'était
l'objet de la question de votre collègue
sénateur il y a une seconde nous parlons
là de l'argent de nos concitoyens et 55
milliards c'est effectivement une somme
extrêmement importante c'est juste nos
dépenses d'assurance maladie qui ont
augmenté de 55 milliards dont la moitié
au bénéfice des établissements de santé
vous le savez la réponse à la crise du
covid-19 le Ségure de la Santé a apporté
une réponse forte parce qu'on peut d'un
côté la main sur le cœur dire les
soignants les soignants et ne jamais
apporter de réponse concrète dans le
segure en fonctionnement il y a 8
milliards ces 8 milliards c'est du
concret ils ont été attribués au
personnel de santé ils ont vu une
augmentation de leur rémunération c'est
tellement vrai d'ailleurs que cette
dernière augmentation elle date du mois
de janvier dernier avec la prise en
charge des weekends la prise en charge
des garde de nuit c'était attendu c'est
fait maintenant il reste une deuxième
partie ce sont les 19 milliards
d'investissements et cela c'est sur
l'ensemble du territoire la mise en
place de travaux de rénovation de
construction il y a 10 jours que je suis
là depuis 10 jours les uns après les
autres vous m'interpellez sur les
projets de vos hôpitaux alors oui
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ces
crédits nous en avons besoin et ma
feuille de route c'est qu'il deviennent
réalité sur le terrain au plus tôt
madame
lérou madame la ministre force de
constater que les conditions de travail
des professionnels se dégradent et que
les difficultés d'accès aux soins
persistent plus de blab blabla des actes
voilà ce que demandent les Français et
puis je voulais vous dire madame la
ministre vous l'avez évoqué la santé
n'est pas gratuite pour les Français
comme vous le dites dans la presse
régionale il contribue chaque mois par
la CSG par les cotisations pour accéder
aux soins ils attendent un service
public à la hauteur de leur de leur
engagement et pourtant les listes
d'attente pour les opérations
s'allongent les déprogrammations
d'intervention se multiplient mettant en
danger la la santé de millions de
Français la désertification médicale a
conduit de nombreux hôpitaux à recruter
des médecins hors de l'UE or les padus
sont menacés de prendre leur postees de
perdre leurs postees en raison de
l'extinction légale de certains statut
la régularisation urgente des médecins
diplômés à l'étranger
s'impose la parole est à notre collègue
Christina Pluchet pour le groupe
républain merci monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
Président alors ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Premier ministre monsieur le
Premier ministre j'entends depuis
plusieurs années les déclarations du
président de la République et des
ministre de l'Agriculture successive
promettant la main sur le cœur de
défendre l'agriculture française et la
souveraineté aliment
mais j'entends surtout directement sur
le terrain le monde agricole qui gronde
toujours plus oublié
asphyxiier mépriser depuis 10 ans nous
alertons contre les inepsies
idéologiques qui sont devenus le nouveau
crédau de votre majorité et de nos
institutions et jusqu'à la Cour des
comptes devenu curieusement compétente
en déjection
bovine monsieur le prés Monsieur le
Premier Ministre qui a soutenu la
stratégie européenne farm to fork et sa
surenchair normative malgré les alertes
répété des par parlementaire européen LR
c'est Renaissance c'est votre majorité
au Parlement européen qui a soutenu au
Parlement européen la proposition de
règlement sur la restauration de la
nature qui prévoyait 10 % de cher
agricole encore Renaissance qui a refusé
d'activer la clause de sauvegarde sur le
poulet ukrainien votre gouvernement qui
a approuvé au Parlement européen
l'accord de libre échange avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande toujours Renaissance et
qui a refusé au Sénat de voter sur le
CTA toujours votre majorité je m'arrête
là mais la liste est longue et pourtant
notre survie dépend bien de celle du
monde agricole cette crise elle met le
projecteur sur votre absence de cap et
sur les effets délétaires du en même
temps comment pouvez-vous assumer un
discours à Paris et des votes inverses à
Strasbourg alors Monsieur le Premier
Ministre ma question est simple
qu'attendez-vous pour dénoncer les
délires de vos représentants à Bruxelles
et soutenir vraiment l'agriculture et
les agriculteurs
français la parole est à monsieur le
ministre de l'Agriculture de la
souveraineté
alimentaire merci monsieur le Président
mais ça mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice plucher
j'ai peur d'être obligé de rappeler un
certain nombre de vérité sur un certain
nombre de textes et de votes au
Parlement
européen parce que le groupe dans lequel
sont vos représentants le groupe du PPE
il a voté une grande partie des textes
que vous évoquez y compris attendez
attendez oui mais
on prre
et donc vous me permettrez de dire que
sur un certain nombre de sujets en
particulier sur les sujets
réglementaires de la P qui se sont
associé au texes qui ont été votés il
faut assumer on peut pas avoir de double
discours pardon madame la
sénatrice laissez-moi finir on peut pas
avoir de double discours parce que quand
ça vous arrangerait de se défausser des
votes qui ont été assumés par vos
représentant au Parlement européen alors
madame la sénatrice on va essayer
d'aller plus loin il y a des sujets sur
lesquels il faut qu'on avance et qu'on
avance différemment je l'ai dit sur la
question du Green Deal personne n'a
trouvé grand chose à dire au moment du
Green Deal personne non plus ne s'est
interrogé assez je le dis pour nous-même
mais ça doit être valable pour nous tous
sur la question de la compatibilité en
ces exigences entre ces exigences
environnementales et les capacités
productive de la France je vous rappelle
au au passage que la présidente de la
Commission européenne elle-même elle est
membre plutôt d'une obédience politique
qui est proche de la vôtre et donc il
faut que mais chacun doit assumer sa
part et donc on a besoin de travailler
là-dessus qui s'est opposé
qui s'est opposé au Traité du Mercosur
et à l' au traité sur australien c'est
la
France et pardon de vous dire parce que
je ne voudrais pas non plus qu'on laisse
à croire que l'agriculture a pas besoin
d'exportation 50 % de nos céréales sont
exporté les fromages chez 3 milliards
d'exportation les vins et spiritueux si
on les exporte pas qu'est-ce qu'on fait
et donc on a besoin de commerce madame
la sénatrice mais on a besoin de
commerce dans des règles qui soient des
règles mieux coordonné au niveau
européen donc on a besoin plutôt de plus
d'Europe que MOS d'Europe et on a besoin
de ne pas se laisser aller à quelque
chose qui serait soit un replili
certains le proposent une forme
d'autarcie et par ailleurs de dénoncer
des choses que par ailleurs on
soutient madame
plucher merci Monsieur le Ministre
écoutez moi je sais que
la délégation pardon française a défendu
avec force l'agriculture au Parlement
européen et mais ce que j'entends
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre sur les
barrages c'est que les agriculteurs ils
sont très en colère et ils en ont r bol
du bal des faocu aujourd'hui faites
votre job sortez les dents à Bruxelles
et défendez enfin les intérêts de
l'agriculture française merci
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Annique billon pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je souhaite
associer à cette question le président
Hervé Marseille et les 52 collègues qui
ont cossigné notre lettre ouverte sur
l'interdiction de la pêche dans le golfe
de Gascogne depuis 2 jours 500 navires
français restqu suite à un arrêt du
Conseil d'État afin de limiter les
prises accidentelles de dauphins ce
chage ce chômage forcé d'un mois
renouvelable en 2025 et 2026 ajoute à la
crise d'une pêche française déjà
éprouvée par la crise du covid
l'explosion du coût des énergies le
brexit le conflit ukrainien ou encore
les côas Européens le mois de fermeture
va représenter une perte de 3300 tonnes
soit 14 millions d'euros l'ABS de pêche
va impacter directement les criers le
marchage les poissonneries les
coopératives de producteurs les
entreprise de maintenance un pêcheur en
mer quatre emplois à terre c'est tout un
écosystème qui se retrouve en cale sèche
pourtant les pêcheurs français sensibles
au problèmes des prises accidentelles
ont investi 30 millions d'euros dans des
systèmes répulsifs vous avez annoncé des
aides pour dédommager les pêcheurs ces
réponses ne sont que partiel le monde de
la pêche ne demande pas des
indemnisations il ne demande pas
l'auobol il demande à faire son métier
deux questions monsieur le ministre sans
capitaine à bord du navire- pêche quel
cap envisagez-vous prendre pour éviter
le naufrage d'une filière tout entière
comment pouvez-vous prendre l'engagement
que les poissons consommés respecteront
des normes aussi contraignantes que
celles imposé à nos pêcheurs français
à l'instar des agriculteurs les pêcheurs
sont en colère c'est notre souveraineté
alimentaire qui
s'exprime pour vous répondre la parole
au ministre de la transition écologique
monsieur
béch madame la sénatrice Annique
Bill dans l'urgence et nous sommes dans
cette urgence puisque vous je le redit
c'est une décision du Conseil d'État du
22 décembre qui nous amène à cette
situation j'aurais préféré comme les
pêcheurs que nous puissions disposer de
davantage de temps pour être capable de
déterminer ce qui permettait à la fois
de respecter la biodiversité marine et
je sais l'attachement des pêcheurs à
l'absence de capsur accidentelle j'ai
pas rencontré un seul professionnel de
la mer qui se réjouit d'une pêche
accidentelle mais de l'autre côté compte
tenu encore une fois des risques qui
existent sur la biodiversité trouver un
équilibre qui permette à tout le monde
de s'y retrouver était une nécessité à
très court terme 80 à 85 % de soutien
sur la perte de chiffre d' faire des
bateaux de plus de 8 m concernés par
cette interdiction l'élargissement au
marayilleur des dispositifs de soutien
pour qu'il ne soit pas oublié un
dialogue avec les collectivités
territoriales qui la plupart du temps
ont la responsabilité des ports la mise
en œuvre de mesure de chômage partiel en
ce qui concerne les criers et au-delà de
ça l'assurance d'une équité avec
l'activation de l'article 13 de la
politique commune des pêchees dit
autrement avec l'interdiction pour les
navires non français de venir dans ce
golf de Gascogne et la mise en place de
contrôle y compris avec l'appui de
bâtiments de la Marine nationale avec
l'accord du ministre des Armées
évidemment sous le patronage du Premier
ministre voilà ce sur quoi nous sommes
notre souverereaineté alimentaire en
matière de pêche malheureusement c'est
un
concept 70 % de la consommation de
poisson dans ce pays provient de
l'étranger et donc on a à la fois un
enjeu de soutenabilité de souveraineté
de juste revenu et sur tous ces items le
sujet c'est comment est-ce que cette
difficulté cette sidération provoquée
par cette fermeture spatio-emporelle
elle nous amène dès la fin de la période
dès le début du mois de mars à nous
retrouver au côté des pêcheurs pour
savoir ce que nous faisons dans un an
dans 2 ans et comment nous concilions
encore une fois non pas des injonctions
contradictoires mais des nécessités
additionnell madame
bon
merci monsieur le ministre en réalité ce
n'est pas en interdisant les pêcheurs
français de pêcher qu'on va améliorer la
balance donc moi je vous le dis il y a
urgence il y a urgence à prendre des
mesures mais il y a urgence surtout à
avoir une vraie stratégie à moyen long
terme avec un capitaine qui l'appte
parce qu'aujourd'hui la filière pêche
elle va elle est en train de couler et
nous en sommes
responsables la parole est à notre
collègue Pierre quiiper pour le groupe
les républicains
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre le 26 juillet prochain
nous aurons l'honneur d'ouvrir les Jeux
Olympiques à Paris sur la scène d'un
claquement de doigt on ferme le fleuve à
toute navigation après tout les
touristes peuvent se passer de bateau
mouche mais ce que la mairie de Paris la
préfecture les ministères concernés les
Jeux Olympiques n'ont absolument pas
anticiper c'est que 60 % des flux
représente 600000 tonnes de céréales de
biocarburant et autres vers le plus
grand port céréalier d'Europe qui est
Roan alors une solution a été proposée
par la haute administration c'est celle
de décaler les moissons c'est celle de
décaler les récoltes en somme la
technocratie nous proposerait de décaler
peut-être aussi l'été alors quelle
réponse concrète le gouvernement entend
apporter à cette situation qui de
transformer en coup de grâce pour les
agriculteurs dans cette période
majeure pour vous répondre la parole est
la ministre de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques monsieur le sénateur
cuiper le déroulement sur la scène de la
cérémonie d'ouverture du 26 juillet est
une première hors d'un stade et sur un
fleuv son organisation impose
nécessairement de prendre des mesures
pour tenir compte de ce cadre qui est
très singulier la fermeture à la
navigation de la scène elle est
nécessaire avant la cérémonie pour
opérer le déminage des ponts des Cais
des bateaux et pour monter le décor du
spectacle une concertation approfondie a
été engagée par le préfet de la région
Île-de-France avec l'ensemble des
personnes impactées non pas pour décaler
les moissons ni les récoltes ni les thé
mais pour vraiment apporter des
solutions aux demandes qui ont été
formulées avec les représentants des
céréaliers un le raccourcissement de la
durée de fermeture de la navigation
avant la cérémonie ce délai a déjà été
réduit de 8 à 7 jours et un travail
d'optimisation se poursuit en liaison
avec toutes les parties prenantes de
l'allongement des horaires d'ouverture
des écluses cette demande a en lien avec
voie navigable de France d'ors et déjà
été satisfaite 3 l'identification de
plus de zones de stockage en aval et en
amont de la zone fermée à la navigation
les premiers résultats en lien avec
aROPA ont été partagés avec la
profession 4 un point d'entrée unique
auprès des autorités pour traiter
d'éventueles difficultés pendant les
jeux là aussi cette demande a été
satisfaite 5 le traitement des éventuels
préjudices une méthode de travail est en
place pour l'assurer les épreuves sur la
scène je pense à la natation au
triathlon ne poseront pas les mêmes
difficultés pour les céréaliers puisque
chaque jour les bateaux pourront
circuler après le 26 juillet mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs soyez sûr que
les impacts liés à l'organisation des
Jeux sur le quotidien impact sur la vie
économique sont au cœur de nos
attentions ils sont pris en compte et
ils seront au maximum atténuer je vous
remercie madame la ministre j'entends
bien ce que vous dites pour
autant la réalité c'est que les Jeux
Olympiques c'est dans 4 mois et demi 5
mois et que encore une fois notre
souveraineté alimentaire et énergétique
est menacée elle est fragilisée dans un
contexte de colère et de contestation
c'est le ralbol des agriculteurs et de
l'ensemble des filières alors un arrêt
complet du 18 au 27 juillet serait une
erreur fatale j'entends bien que 3 jours
soi nécessairire pour le déminage et
aussi pour le montage des installations
et puis la réponse a été faite que les
autorités refusent la circulation
fluviale même partiel par peur
d'accident sur les décors du lors du
montage et des cérémonies alors il ne
faut pas prendre les bâteliers pour des
marins d'eau douce si la navigation est
interdite ce sera alors madame la
ministre plus de 500 millions d'euros de
perte pour les filières françaises
comprenez bien que chaque jour de retard
supplémentaire prendrait des proportions
exponentielles vous savez aussi que nous
sommes nous la France les stockurs de
nos clients africains indiens égyptiens
et que si nous ne les livrons pas alors
ils auront eu aussi des conséquences
dramatiques et humaines alors madame la
ministre une solution viable doit être
impérativement je dis bien
impérativement trouvé dans les 15 jours
pour que les filières puissent aussi
s'organiser parole est à notre collègue
flenceatrix pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicain monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chersègues la
liaison ferroviaire transalpine revê une
importance capitale pour l'avenir du
réseau ferroviaire européen en reliant
stratégiquement Lisbonne à Kiev elle
contribuera à la réduction des émissions
de CO2 et permettra d'écarter chaque
année un million de poids lourds des
routes notamment sur nos vallées alpin
elle répond également à l'urgence du
désengorgement de l'Est lyonnais
aujourd'hui saturé d'ici 2032 le tunnel
de base international sera achevé d'une
longueur de 57, 5 km il sera le plus
long tunnel ferroviaire au monde
l'Italie de son côté sera prête à
fournir ses 60 km d'accès et la France
ces hésitations risquent de faire
dérailler le projet car le financement
de l'étude des 150 km d'accès français
n'est toujours pas bouclé pourtant une
échéance cruciale approche à très grande
vitesse le 30 janvier est la date limite
pour la demande de subvention auprès de
l'Union européenne qui pourrait financer
50 % des études des élus de toute
sensibilité politique tirent pourtant le
signal d'alarme depuis longtemps mais
les tentative de réunir le reste du
financement entre l'État et les
collectivités locales ont encore échoué
lors de la réunion du 18 janvier dernier
40 millions d'euros sont toujours à
trouver devant l'urgence de la situation
nous ne pouvons que regretter l'absence
d'un ministre des Transports et les
attermoimements de la région Auvergne
ronalpe mais cela ne doit en aucun cas
compromettre l'obtention de ces
financements indispensa monsieur le
ministre la France va-t-elle rester à
quai la France va-t-elle renier sa
parole et rater son rendez-vous avec
l'Europe et ses territoires pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre de la
cohésion des territoires de la
transition écologique monsieur
Béchu madame la sénatrice blatrice
contrat lyonurin c'est non seulement
majeur pour le report modal de la route
vers le fer c'est majeur pour diminuer
la pollution dans les vallées alpines et
c'est majeur pour les liens entre nos
pays le 30 janvier c'est évidemment une
date qui est dans mon agenda qu'il était
déjà avant le remaniement dernier
puisque c'est la date à laquelle nous
devons notifier à la Commission
européenne le bouclage de la part
française des financements pour les
études permettant à la fois les accès
alpin et le raccordement au
contournement ferroviaire de
l'agglomération lyonnaise
quelques
chiffres 220 millions d'euros c'est le
coût global de ces études extrêmement
ambitieuses pour réaliser l'ensemble de
ces raccordements la part de l'Europe
c'est 50 % mais ça représente 90
millions d'euros puisqu'il y a 38
millions sur les 220 qui ne sont pas
éligibles pour faire simple il reste
donc 130 millions d'euros à financer
dans ces 130 l'État s'est engagé de
manière extrêmement rapide sur les 65
millions correspondant à 50 % de la
somme non subventionnée par l'Europe sur
les 65 qui restent à la minute où nous
parlons 25 côté collectivité et donc un
delta de 40 que vous venez d'évoquer
dans ce delta de 40 millions ce qui se
joue c'est que 13 million d'euros
notamment de la part de la région ouver
in ronalpe c'est une somme qui nous
semble faible à la fois par rapport à la
capacité financière de la région au
retombées économiqu que nous pouvons en
attendre et donc les discussions vous
dites qu'elles ont échoué je dirais mais
c'est très sérieux qu'elles n'ont pas
abouti parce qu'il n'y a aucune
hypothèse où le 30 janvier les
discussions échouent ce qui se joue ça
n'est pas qu'un bouclage financier c'est
la réalisation d'un projet qui nous
permettra de bénéficier de subvention
massives de la part de l'Union
européenne et qui nous permet de porter
une ambition écologique qui soit
concrète et qui soit pas seulement de
papier matrice contard vous avez
quelques secondes monsieur
monsieur le ministre réussir cette étape
est un impératif si l'on veut éviter une
gabgie c'est-à-dire un tunnel sans train
ou avec la moitié de sa capacité ce sera
un échec pour la décarbonation de nos
transports ce serait l'échec de la
France la parole est à notre collègue
catherinerti pour le groupe les
républicains merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le
ministreassage de pomp la jolie
d'enseignant angoulem policiers de la
BAC ass à Marseille plus que jamais la
crise de l'autorité svie dans notre
République les agressions contre nos
sapurs pompiers ont augmenté de plus de
30 % depuis 2020 pour ce qui des
enseignants je suis bien placé pour
connaître l'ampleur de la crise
d'évocation qui touche la profession
aujourd'hui enseigner ce n'est plus
simplement dispenser un savoir à la
jeune génération mais cela consiste
aussi à préserver sa liberté
d'expression face aux menaces verbales
et physiques enfin que dire de nos
policiers et gendarmes dont les
démissions se compent en milliers chaque
année face au manque de reconnaissance
de moyens et de respect pour leur action
au service de tous je n'oublie pas non
plus nos élus locaux dont le mandat
tempend à être non seulement un
engagement civique mais qui sont
aujourd'hui trop souvent menacés dans
leur propre intégr intégrité F je tiens
à vous rappeler que le Sénat a voté à
l'unanimité en octobre dernier une
proposition de loi émanant de la
majorité sénatoriale qui visait à
renforcer la sécurité des élus et la
protection des maires le volet pénal de
C aussi propose notamment d'aligner les
peines sur le régime existant pour les
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
toutes ces professions font l'honneur de
la France et si lesévocation de ceux qui
les exercent sont différentes leurs mots
ont la même racine un rejet croissant de
l'autorité de l'État par une partie de
la population deux questions monsieur le
ministre à quelques mois des JO comment
le gouvernement comp-il empêcher des
incidents plus graves encore et d'autre
part quand n quand nos élus locaux
pourront-ils bénéficier de la protection
renforcée que le Sénat leur a accordé
pour répondre la parole est au ministre
en charge de la cohésion des territoires
monsieurs
monsieur madame la
sénatrice depuis quelques jours l'année
2023 est terminé et donc les décomptes
d'un certain nombre de choses commencent
vous avez cité les pompiers juste pour
vous donner un
chiffre on ne peut pas se satisfaire que
nous ayons enregistré 100 agressions de
moins c'est bien que ce soit en moins
mais quand on est à 1400 par an de
sapeur Pompi et je vous demande de
méditer ce chiffre que 70 % des
agresseurs son ceux auxquels les
pompiers portaient secours on mesure à
quel point il y a quand même des
comportements dans notre pays qui ne
vont pas on est dans quelque chose
d'irrationnel vous faites sauver et vous
agressez la personne qui vient vous
secourir à bien des égards les violences
contre les élus elles résultent de la
même déconstruction mentale de de la
même absence de bon sens de cohérence de
rationalité et même de respect vous avez
rappelé il y a eu ce texte vter à
l'unanimité du Sénat et voter à
l'unanimité de l'assemblée et je veux
saluer le dépôt il y a quelques jours à
l'initiative du président retaillot du
président Marseille et de la présidente
Gatel d'une PPL portant création d'un
statut de l'élu parce que nous savons
que ce qui motive l'engagement des élus
c'est pas le fait de se savoir protéger
c'est le fait de penser qu'ils auront à
la fois les moyens de pouvoir aider
leurs concitoyens avec parfois là aussi
un ralbol normatif et dans dans d'autres
cas que les conséquences sur leur vie
personnelle de cet engagement elle soi
mesurée et qu' leur permettent néanmoins
de pouvoir la concilier avec des projets
et avec une vie familiale normale dans
la continuité du texte qui a été voté au
Sénat dans la continuité des travaux qui
ont été conduites par Dominique fort à
laquelle je pense en cet instant 3400
policiers et gendarmes sont aujourd'hui
référents
élus le centre d'analyse de suivi qui
enregistre notamment le fait que des
élus sa pour bénéficier d'un suivi
particulier a connu 2500 inscriptions en
toute fin d'année dernière dans la
continuité de ce texte les formations se
poursuivent elles se multiplient les
instructions envoyées au préfet
notamment par le ministre de l'Intérieur
et des outres mèes dont je j'excuse
l'absence continue elle aussi à se
multiplier et très bientôt il aura
l'occasion de pouvoir vous présenter un
bilan plus complet
Mad merci monsieur le ministre je vois
que vous faites le même constat que moi
mais votre réponse dénote une nouvelle
fois de l'incapacité de l'exécutif à
répondre concrètement aux problématiques
quotidiennes des Français et de
l'inventivité que le gouvernement
déploie au contraire à formuler des
promesses qui me semblent être sans
lendemain la parole est à notre collègue
Florence lassarade pour le groupe les
républicains monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
les AG ur souffre les pêcheurs aussi la
pêche est désormais interdite dans le
golf de Gascogne à tous les bateaux de
plus de 8 m pendant un mois cet arrêt
d'un mois doit se répéter pendant les
hivers 2025- 2026 au nom de la
protection des dauphins ainsi plus de
450 navires vont rester à qu au moment
le plus prolifique pour les pêcheurs
c'est toute une filière qui est menacée
à l'origine de cette mesure radicale une
décision du Conseil d'État visant à
protéger les dauphins des captures
accidentelles par les marins pêcheurs
pour pourtant des dérogations pour les
navires avaient été initialement prévues
et de nombreux pêcheurs avaient consenti
à ces investissements en s'équipant de
dispositif de dissuasion acoustique et
de caméras embarqué d'autres solutions
existaient les représentants de la
filière avaient par exemple proposé la
fermeture tournante des zones de pêche
cette interdiction a été étendue à tous
les navires européens et comme on
pouvait s'en douter elle a suscité de
vivre et action l'Association européenne
des organisations de producteurs de
poisson a appelé la Commission
européenne la tranchée estimant que
cette décision unilatérale pénalise
toute la filière pêche de l'Union
européenne et considère que cette
jurisprudence ne devrait s'appliquer
qu'au navires français en attendant la
décision de la Commission pendant un
mois les pêcheurs espagnols pourront eux
tranquillement continuer à pêcher
concurrencer les Français enfin comble
de l'Absurde la communauté scientifique
européenne estime que depuis 20 ans la
population des dauphins communs est
stable et ne court aucun risque à court
terme dans le golfe de Gascogne avec
avec moins de produits de la mer
prélevés les prix sur les étales des
Poissonniers vont s'envoler le risque
est aussi de voir la part des poissons
importés progresser monsieur le ministre
face à cette décision radicale absurde
injuste et dispondieuse quelles sont vos
propositions pour sauvegarder une
filière pêche française et laisser les
pêcheurs professionnels exercer leur
profession monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
ministre monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice
la décision que vous contestez avec
force ça n'est pas une décision
politique c'est une décision de justice
qui est celle du Conseil d'État je vous
laisse évidemment
l'entièreté l'entière liberté dans le
fait de dénoncer à la fois un consensus
scientifique ou les bases sur lesquelles
ces décisions on été pris moi dans les
fonctions qui sont les miennes la
responsabilité qu'elle la nôtre elle est
d'appliquer des décisions de justice je
précise que des arrêts temporaires n'ont
pas commencé avec les dauphins il y a eu
des arrêts temporaires pour pour la sole
il y en a encore pour les civelles avec
des cas dans lesquels des interdictions
étaient mises en place le gouvernement a
proposer à travailler avec les pêcheurs
pour que nous n'ayons pas une fermeture
spatiautemporelle pure mais qu'il ait
des dérogations c'est ça qui est l'objet
de l'annulation par le Conseil d'État
face à cette situation notre
responsabilité
elle est de soutenir la totalité de la
filière de l'amont à laaval et elle est
ensuite au-delà de la période de crise
dans laquelle nous sommes de de
réfléchir avec du du temps à ce qui
devra se passer dans un an en revanche
je ne peux pas vous laisser dire qu'à la
minute où nous parlons nous sommes en
absurd sur l'application de ce
dispositif en fonction de la nationalité
des bateaux l'article 13 a été appliqué
sans délai l'interdiction vaut pour tous
les navires de plus de 8 m et pas
seulement les navires français c'est
effectif depuis lundi matin 1ière heure
et c'est non seulement contrôlé par les
préfectures maritimes mais c'est
également contrôlé par des navires et
par des avions de la Marine nationale
les sanctions auxquelles s'exposent les
navires de plus de 8 m ne sont pas liés
à la couleur de leur pavillon mais au
fait de croiser dans ces eau du golfe de
Gascogne c'était évidemment la première
attente du Comité des pêches qu'il y ait
pas cette distorsion cette mesure elle
est effective je le redis depuis la
première heure nous pouvons discuter de
la fermeture de ses délais de son
indemnisation mais certainement pas de
son respect et de son étendue parce que
dans ce domaine le gouvernement a pris
ses responsabilités et les choses sont
claires depuis la première heure madame
la sarade vous avez quelques
secondes comme pour l'agriculture avec
les arguments erronés des ONG antipêche
vous condisez le pays à l'insurrection
ni plus ni
moins merci je voudrais informer le
Sénat je voudrais informer le Sénat que
mercredi prochain à 15h nous entendrons
une déclaration du gouvernement suivie
d' un débat en application de l'article
50-1 de notre Constitution la Conférence
des Présidents confirmera cet après-midi
même ce point à l'ordre du jour en
conséquence notre prochaine séance de
question d'actualité au gouvernement
aura lieu le mercredi 7 février je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
16h30 pour l'examen de la proposition de
loi adoptée avec modification par
l'Assemblée nationale en 2uxè lecture
qui vise à protéger le groupe
Électricité de France d'un membrement la
séance est
suspendue et vous avez donc pu suivre
cette séance de questions au
Gouvernement direct et en intégralité
sur Public Sénat on va tout de suite
rejoindre Audrey vetas dans l'hémicycle
du Sénat
Audrey on peut dire que c'était une
séance animée elle a été largement
dominée par ce sujet de l'agriculture
oui avec huit questions en rapport avec
l'agriculture avec pour mener la charge
plusieurs sénateurs agriculteurs de
profession d'ailleurs certaines de ces
interpellations ont plus ressemblé à des
tribunes qu'à de vraies questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement écoutez la
question justement ou l'interpellation
du sénateur LR Laurent Duplomb de son
propre aveu je n'ai pas de question à
vous posertant l'accumulation des
problème que l'agriculture rencontre
résume à elle seul le mal français les
mots ne suffisent plus à calmer ce mal
il faut des actes faites rentrer et
retonz vos tigres qui sont de la dral de
la DDT de l'ofb de la ddspp de
l'inspection du travail ou de la police
de l'eau afin qu'ils arrêtent cette
cette pression insupportable fait terire
par des arbitrage favorable à
l'agriculture tous ces soldats vert du
ministère de l'écologie punitive faites
cesser en même en même temps de votre
propre majorité avec un campfin
promoteur de la décroissance et du Green
Deal car en même temps ne ce con jug pas
en agriculture faites confiance au bon
sens plutôt qu'à cettee qu'à cette
gauche bobo qui n'a de cesse de donner
des le sang et de produire des interdits
vous l'aurez entendu une séance très
emportée au moment où Laurent Duplomb
pointe du doigt les écologistes comme
l'une des sources d'une partie du mal
des agriculteurs applaudissement à
droite hurlement à gauche qui en a
profité pour taper sur les pupitres pour
vous dire le son le micro du sénateur du
plomb a été coup pour qu'il s'arrête de
parler d'interpeller et ce n'est pas le
seul moment he où le ton est monté
écoutez l'intervention de Marc fenau le
ministre de l'Agriculture quand il
fustige l'agribashing écologiste et la
réponse de Daniel salmon écologiste
justement il faut vous dites on a fait
de l'écologie un
épouvantail collectivement monsieur
salmon pardon il faut qu'on arrête dans
les médias et à longueur de médias de
dire du mal de l'agriculture et de de de
montrer une agriculture n'est pas la
réalité de l'agriculture française
l'agriculture française elle est
vertueuse elle est performante elle est
qualité vous oubliez un peu que ça fait
7 ans 7 années que vous êtes au pouvoir
qu'avez-vous fait sur les closuses
miroir dont on entend parler en
permanence qu'avez-vous fait pour une
autre répartition de la PAC avec tous
ces oubliés de la PAC qu'avez-vous fait
pour accompagner massivement la
transition agroécologique dont on a
besoin absolument cet après-midi tame
l'hémicycle c'est largement coupé en
deux entre la gauche et la droite
pourtant quand on les écoute dans le
détail tous proposent les mêmes
solutions des mesures miroir entre la
France et les autres pays et une
simplification des normes à Notter aussi
et ça on l'a appris tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle pendant la séance le groupe
socialiste demande au président du Sénat
une commission la constitution d'une
commission d'enquête sur la question des
revenus agricoles et des relation
commerciales agroalimenta il demande
plus de transparence merci merci
beaucoup audrait pour toutes ces
explications autour de cette séance qui
a été largement consacré à la question
agricole mais il y a aussi eu d'autres
sujets notamment une question sur
l'hôpital public qui a été posée à
Catherine vaterin la ministre du Travail
de la santé et des solidarités elle est
d'ailleurs à votre micro Quentin oui
bonjour Catherine merci d'avoir accepté
cette interview en direct sur antinne de
Public Sénat ce sont vos premier pas à
nouveau en tant que membre du
gouvernement à la Chambre haute du
parlement on rappelle vous avez été
ministre des
sous et bien Jacques Chirac il y a
quelques années vous allez être
auditionné dans quelques instants sur le
bienveillir que dire de votre feuille de
route de votre ambition à la tête de ce
super ministère vous l'avez compris ce
ministère est à la fois le ministère du
quotidien du quotidien puisque la
responsabilité est celle que nos
concitoyens soient en bonne santé de la
naissance jusqu'au dernier souffle c'est
évidemment tout ce qui tourne autour de
l'équipement du social du médicos-social
l'hôpital les structures méd pocial
cette ce travail cette activité qui est
celle de la proximité et puis le travail
avec évidemment cette volonté que nous
portons avec le président de la
République qui est celle de l' qui est
celle de l'émancipation par le travail
d'accord donc c'est c'est c'est le
premier c'est la premier objectif pour
vous l'éman par le travail pour moi
l'émancipation par le travail c'est
permettre à celles et ceux qui sont
éloignés de d'avoir la capacité de
retourner et c'est aussi dans l'aspect
médico-social où nous le savons nous
avons des places d'assistantes maternell
des plac
également auprès de nos aînés qui sont à
pourvoirut essayer de former apporter
des réponses voilà des sujets très
concrets pour le cotidien des Françaises
et des Français il y a de grandes
inquiétudes on l'a entendu lors de cette
séance de questions au Gouvernement sur
l'hôpital public hein vous avez été
interrogé sur cette question avec en
plus 12 milliards à faire dans les
économies du budget de l'État c'est ce
que veut Bruno Le Maire ça va pas être
une équation impossible à tenir un
casse-etête pour vous mais vous l'avez
vu il y a un point très important c'est
le segéur qui a été voté le Segur deux
projets le premier c'est le
fonctionnement c'est la revalorisation
pour les soignants 8 milliards c'est
fait c'est versé le deuxème c'est
l'équipement parce que avoir un meilleur
équipement c'est apporter des solutions
encore plus performantes et ça c'est 19
milliards ma feuille de route c'est de
les appliquer dans les meilleurs délais
j'ai deux rapide question si vous voulez
bien Catherine Vautrin le président de
la Mutualité Française Éric Chenu qui
vous a écrit qui parle d'un moment
charnière dans lequel se trouve la
France en 2024 et qui dit que l'approche
courttermiste et comptable en vigueur ne
pourra jamais être synonyme de bien
commun c'est une lettre ouverte qui vous
a adressé qu'est-ce que vous lui
répondez ben d'abord je lui a réponds
que nous allons nous voir pour échanger
ensemble parce que je crois que notre
responsabilité c'est de l'utilisation de
l'argent des Français dont il s'agit
d'un côté et la question qui se pose
c'est notre responsabilité face à
l'héritage potentiel qu'on pourrait
laisser à nos enfants c'est celui de la
dette donc tout l'intérêt c'est à la
fois le plus de bonne santé possible le
plus de création de valeur par le
travail pour limiter la dette ouis et à
propos des mutuels cette augmentation de
8 % en moyenne de leur prix qu'est-ce
que ça vous évoque ça fait partie des
sujets sur lesquels nous devons
travailler avec les mutuels et aussi en
responsabilité avec nos concitoyens
notamment sur le bon usage du médicament
et justement sur le bon usage des
médicaments le doublement des franchise
ça risque pas de peser dans le POR des
des Français au on est en personne de
vœux ça vous en période de vœux ça vous
a pas échappé tous les soirs on se dit
bonne santé et bien quelque part quand
on s'intéresse à sa santé il y a un
premier sujet c'est la prévention que
l'on peut voir les uns et les autres et
deuxièmement participer à hauteur de 1 €
je crois que c'est possible c'est
d'autant plus possible que pour les
affections longue durée il y a un
forfait que nous respectons qui est de
4,1 € par mois et bien merci merci pour
toutes ces réponses au micro de public
là je vous libère qu' vousz rejoindre la
salle de la commission pour cette
audition qui a lieu maintenant merci
merci beaucoup merci merci à beaucoup
Quentin pour cette première interview
puis on va revenir aussi et bien au
principal sujet de cette séance hein on
disait cette séance qui qui a été
largement consacré au sujet de
l'agriculture et Quentin vous êtes avec
le sénateur écologiste du Rône c'est
Thomas dosur tout à fait Tam bonjour
Thomas Dosu on a entendu Marc fen s'en
prendre un peu aux écologistes en disant
qu'il fallait réconcilier les Français
avec leurs agriculteurs il faut qu'on
arrête de dire du mal de l'agriculture
dans les médias à plaider Marc fenau
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez il a
semblé sans prendre aux écologistes oui
alors moi je me sens pas du tout ciblé
par par ce genre d'attaque moi je pense
pas qu'on dise du mal de de de
l'agriculture je pense que au contraire
les écologistes ont bon dos et qui
servent de Bou émissaire à certains qui
qui défendent un modèle depuis des
années qui précaris les agriculteurs et
qui mettent en mettent en danger la vie
de certains agriculteurs par le libre
échange par des une pression éternelle
sur les prix on voit que c'est un une
crise agricole qui est multifactorielle
on a dit protéiforme qu'est-ce que vous
avez pensé des des réponses de marquef
lors de cette séance de question au
gouvernement il y a des choses concrètes
que vous retournez de son
vousour la question centrale c'est le
revenu des agriculteurs aujourd'hui on
est dans un modèle qui est complètement
fou c'estàdire qu'on a 9 millions de
Français qui arrivent pas à se nourrir
qui ont faim qui disent sauter des repas
et de l'autre côté ceux qui produisent
l'alimentation n'arrive pas à se
rémunérer et donc on a entre les deux
une agroindustrie et la grande
distribution qui met la pression aux
agriculteurs et qui font que le partage
de la valeur n'est pas équitable au sein
de de ce modèle là le gouvernement dit
qu'il s'en occupe depuis 2017 notamment
avec les lois égalim égalim 2 même
qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez c'est
c'est pas ces petits bras il faut
davantage de en fait en fait on on en
est plus à aux grandes déclarations ça
fait 6 ans qu'ils sont au pouvoir nous
ça fait 6 ans qu'on débat avec eux sur
ces sujets et on voit bien là que le
résultat n'est pas là c'est-à-dire que
ce sujet du partage de la valeur et du
revenu agricole il date pas
d'aujourd'hui il date pas de de ce
mois-ci ça fait longtemps qu'on qu'on
qu'on entend parler de de ça et qu'on
voit bien que les petits n'arrivent pas
à survivre donc tout l'enjeu maintenant
il est de trouver des solutions rapides
pour que pu ils puissent vivre de leur
production Yannick jado ce matin qui a
parlé d'un deux poids de mesures sur les
mobilisations il a dit c'est évident les
écologistes feraient le millième de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui ils seraient en
prison et condamné qu'est-ce que ça vous
évoque cette phrase de V candidat à
l'élection présidentielle oui oui je
pense que c'est même si moi je pense que
c'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui en
réalité oui il y a des modes de
mobilisation qui sont plus légitimes
quand c'est les agriculteurs quand ce
sont les écologistes qui les mettent en
œuvre vous regrettez non pas
spécialement en réalité moi je je vais
pas condamner un mode ou un autre ou
encore une fois opposé de de de modes
d'action moi ce qui m'intéresse
maintenant c'est qu'on réponde à la
colère c'est tout et j'ai une dernière
question si vous le voulez bien il y a
beaucoup de choses qui vont se jouer à
Bruxelles parce que la plupart des
normes 80 % qui pèsent sur les
agriculteurs viennent de l'UE vous
pensez que la Commission est capable
d'agir suffisamment agilement face à
cette crise c'est un enjeu européen on
le voit bien dans tous les pays des
conations deain qui à fait on sait que
l'Europe a toujours du mal à réagir
assez vite moi ce que je demande c'est
qu'on arrête de négocier des traités de
libre échange il y a une grande
hypocrisie là-dessus puisque la France
pousse à la à ces traités de libre
échange et et après nous dit ici qu'elle
veul protéger les agricul
des importations étrangères on voit bien
qu'il y a une hypocrisie je pense qu'il
faut d'abord cesser cette hypocrisie et
bien merci merci Thomas DSU pour cette
réaction en direct sur public sénatam
merci merci beaucoup Quentin pour toutes
ces réactions politiques sal des
conférences et on va parler lors de ce
débrief et bien de cette crise agricole
qui a largement et occupé et bien cette
séance de question au gouvernement sur
ce plateau j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
Martha sdrag bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice les républicains des ivelines
et vice-présidente de la Commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable à côté de vous
Bernard buit bonjour bon vous êtes
sénateur renaissance de la Drome et
vice-président de la commission des
affaires économiques et enfin
Jean-Claude tissau sénateur socialiste
de la Loire membre de la commission des
affaires économiques agriculteur de
profession et on vous a entendu tout à
l'heure interpeller le gouvernement tout
d'abord un mot et bien bien sûr sur
votre diagnosticque sur cette crise
alors que le mouvement s'étend on a une
carte des blocages aujourd'hui bien on
parle de 85 départements qui sont
concernés qui ont des points de blocage
avec un mouvement qui ne va faire que
s'étendre jusqu'à vendredi le mouvement
on le rappelle et bien il est parti
d'Occitanie et il a ensuite gagné toutes
les régions il va y avoir des actions
qui vont être mené de Bayonne à la
Bretagne en passant par Lyon orléon la
colère des agriculteurs elle est très
forte des crises dans l'agriculture
bernabbis ce n'est pas une nouveauté
mais aujourd'hui on entendu le président
de la FNS qui parle d'une colère inédite
en quoi est-ce que c'est inédit est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ce constat
alors colère inédite je sais pas on
avait eu la crise des Bonet rouges en
Bretagne en 2013 ça partait aussi de
l'écotaxe qui avait été mise en place et
qui a fallu retirer devant la pression
des agriculteurs aujourd'hui
effectivement on a une manifestation de
masse du mouvement agricole en France
mais pas qu'en France puisque ces
manifestants ont commencé partout
ailleurs en Europe je dirais que la
France